[Music]
i'll be home in the morning where are
you going i'm staying over at susie's
tonight
what's new
the flyer
the papers call him the grabber i wish
you wouldn't call that you don't
actually believe that story do you
because he can't hear you and he doesn't
really take kids that say
oh
you goof beautiful isn't that just
peachy cute you need some help you see
that
would you hand me my hat
yes sir
i
am a part-time magician
are those type of ones in there
would you like to see a magic trick
i have an announcement to make one of
our students finney blake was abducted
what if i could help the police find
penny
[Applause]
[Music]
doesn't work
not since i was a kid
i'll scream i'll scratch your face
this face
daddy i had a dream about it what
happened in your dream he was taken by a
man with black balloons yes we never
release those details
huh don't hang up
who are you
you know
you're getting out of here
please please let the dreams be real see
the wall in front of you i tore a long
cable loose from down there
there's a combination lock on the inside
of the storm door what's the combination
[Music]
i carved it in the wall
the tree the door the gate i've never
seen you before except in my dreams
you don't have much time
you're gonna use a weapon you raise the
phone step back and swing
look what you made me do
please hurry you remember what i told
you
there's someday i should stand up for
myself someday it's today fan
[Music]
you
[Music]